first time I was at the Stanford campus
I was slightly angry that nobody told me
that this place existed so
it's cool to have to have some business
here I'm uh I would have loved to be a
student here but I'm glad to be able to
give this lecture
um
we uh getlab's mission is to make it so
that everyone can contribute
and what we what we make is a devops
platform a single application that
allows you to do everything from
planning what you want to build create
it package that up secure it deploy that
and monitor what you've built
and
there's a couple of things driving
devops going from multiple tools to a
single application there's more and more
software there's more and more
applications there's more and more tools
to help you in the devops process
and there's more more a need to quickly
onboard people and make developers happy
if you look at the number of tools in
the beginning devops you could do it
with some git some Version Control some
CI today is 10 plus applications
if you look at all the applications
there were a few big projects that a
company had nowadays you have
microservices you have hundreds of
different applications and together
that's that's causing an exponential
growth in the number of Integrations the
beginning companies said hey
any team can bring their own tools can
use their own tools because when devops
was New it is very important to shift to
newer more modern tools really quickly
but it kind of caused the mess because
people teams couldn't communicate across
because they were on their different
tool Stacks so a company said we're
going to standardize on Best in Class
as a company we're going to pick the 10
tools we're going to use we're going to
use
jira for planning GitHub for Version
Control Jenkins 4ci J frog artifactory
for packaging Etc
that really helped everyone was on the
same tool set
but what didn't go very fast is the
cycle time the cycle time is the time
between deciding to do something and
getting it out there and that didn't go
very fast because you because you had to
hop between these different tools
so the company said you know what we're
going to make these Integrations better
so that you lose less context in between
these hops
and then that's the era of DIY devops
this is where 80 of all companies are
now if you're going to work at a company
they say we have Best in Class tools and
you know what we spent the last five
years integrating them better we have
our own kind of
they typically have a really uh fancy
name for it
and also typically it's a worse
experience than you'd have
otherwise because it really allows them
to constrain things but it it is a
really big effort to make something like
this and every company is kind of making
it themselves doing the Integrations
themselves you never kind of get the
tools quite right all the tools have
different concepts different models they
don't quite fit so you try to kind of
duct tape something together
but it the end result looks pretty messy
GitHub is the next phase it's a devops
platform a single application where the
same concepts are used throughout the
application where you don't have to
switch from one interface to another
interface we don't have it that your
colleague doesn't have access to the
same tool or the same credentials
and it allows you to go 10 times faster
we typically see that the cycle time is
reduced at T-Mobile they were able to
deploy 10 times as frequently with
gitlab a Goldman Sachs they went from
two weeks to two hours to make an
improvement in their most important
application
apart from making a devops platform also
known as the largest remote company
before the pandemic
I think now that after the pandemic it's
it feels very natural that you can work
remote it used to be very controversial
um and for us we're one of the first
companies that didn't had a headquarter
our headquarters was in a mailbox
somewhere in a UPS Store
I think
um sometimes people refer to us as a
virtual company and I always find that
pretty funny
I find it funny because a company
inherently is an abstract concept right
your company doesn't doesn't consist of
your furniture or your your building
if anything it may be consist of your
people uh but probably also of your
processes and your systems and the data
and the relationships you have but but
certainly
the headquarters of anything would
matter the least not not the most
I think because there was a lot of
skepticism about being an old remote
company we paid extra attention to
defining our culture
because all the people said like how how
if you're all remote can you create
culture how can you create camaraderie
um culture I think
but I'd love to know if I'm missing one
of these so please add but I think it
consists of three things
what are your what are your values
what is your camaraderie and I think a
big part of that is is trust and
friendship within the within the people
at the company
and how do you work
and we've been very intentional about
all three we have 22 ways in which we
reinforce our values
we explicitly have programs to promote
um kind of meeting each other
I'd like to say we formalize informal
communication
if you have a company that's co-located
the informal communication happens at
the water cooler
or here at the campus
if you are remote it needs to happen in
some other way and we have a bit more
intention around that
um we've shared over 15 ways in which we
you can help that informal communication
and then a company a part of culture is
how you work what you do
and we've been trying to get really
uh maybe a thoughtful maybe prescriptive
almost about that we think there's
there's better ways to work so that you
spend less time on communication on
average
we all like to do a great job at work
and all like to have a little bit time
left and the only way to get there is to
be more efficient and I don't think
um
that Intuition or what people naturally
do is necessarily always optimal I think
there's ways to further improve it and I
think companies can be more opinionated
on how you communicate an example would
be at gitlab we don't present in
meetings we think that can happen async
if you want to present
great sent the slide deck up front if
you want to verbalize it great send a
video up front but give people the
opportunity to watch it at a time of
their choosing maybe a twice speed
instead of
doing this right we made you show up
and and then present but I think they
had a being here synchronous should be
for Q a so it was great to see that
there's a lot of time for that today
we have um
six values of which the most important
ones are results transparency and
iteration
and I'll I'll go
um through them later on we we also have
made something called t-mops it's a
couple of months olds right now and it's
because a lot of things we thought were
very logical doing when you were remote
uh didn't turn out to be very much
connected to being remote
it's more connect connected to like
making the fish decisions and we think
are more efficient and inclusive way
so we we thought of
four principles for team-ups the first
one is a shared reality making sure
everyone is on the same page
and we do that in a couple of ways a
gitlab things are public by default
for example if you uh type in gitlab
unfiltered you'll find a YouTube channel
with a ton of boring meetings
so you have trouble falling asleep
tonight you can
go to a wide selection of meetings
but it just it does reach more people
like if you miss the meeting it's very
easy to see it
um it's on YouTube so you can watch it
on any device and if you plan on
interviewing at gitlab you wonder what
reality is like that is a really great
way to see it
we try to have a single source of truth
I think in a lot of organizations
information is duplicated and if you
duplicate it it's really hard to update
it later you tend to update only one
part and it gets out of sync
so if you look at for example at our
Handbook of over 2000 Pages you'll find
a lot of times things are links that
could also be have been there but we
intentionally link so we don't duplicate
the information
we try to practice low context
communication
if we are synchronous you can be very
fast like I do a ton of meetings and
they're efficient for me because I can
say the minimum and if people are like
this I can elaborate a little bit more
um
if we communicate for example to the
entire company we try to give contacts
on what is going on
and provide like backup materials
whenever possible
we pay a lot of attention to situational
leadership
um
I think I have a blog post out there
with over 13
factors that might factor in of whether
you delegate something or not
I think if you become a leader of any
any sort from manager manager up it's
really important that you adjust your
communication to your audience and it's
going to be different for different
people at different times depending on
the situation
where we're an inclusive company we try
to make sure that people can contribute
and maybe one
one called a trivial but as a simple way
in which we do it is that in meetings we
write down if you want to ask
the next question
so there's a Google doc it's real time
the agenda kind of becomes the notes
during the meeting
and you can write down your name and
your question because if people talk
sometimes some people find it hard to
kind of interrupt or or kind of quickly
raise
their voice and this this allows us to
kind of be
more on an equal playing field between
the different personality types we found
and having shared values and reinforcing
that in 20 different ways
the second thing apart from a shared
reality is making sure that everyone can
contribute it's it's our mission
um and there's lots of ways in which we
try to do that
one way is iteration so we try to make
work as small as possible
and then get it out as quickly as
possible so reducing scope to get it out
quicker that sounds
maybe easy it's it's by far the hardest
thing we do
and it's the only value where I
regularly hold office hours because lots
of times
the way to do that is not intuitive to
to people and frankly to ourselves like
I I frequently get my case it this this
can probably be smaller
and if you make something smaller and
get it out quickly it allows people to
respond to that
the longer the bigger
a chunk of work you're going to ship
the longer it takes before you can
incorporate people their feedback
another
operating principle we have is short
toes
[Music]
and that means that anyone in the
company can give you a suggestion about
what to do
and not all of them are going to be
great suggestions
but they're always welcome you don't
have to listen to them you don't even
have to acknowledge them
we do
we do think you should read them so read
them but you don't have to defend
yourself I think if you if you start
requiring that like where people
acknowledge their contributions
that's a lot of work and then people
will make sure that their projects stay
under the radar so that they don't get
as much feedback
um
a few other things are the dris making
sure that there's for every project
there's one accountable person
informal communication for example this
quarter we had visiting grants
where people got 500 to a thousand
dollars to meet up together
um and we always try to distinguish
one-way door and two-way door decisions
um a one-way door decision is something
that's very hard to reverse a typical
example of that is a a rename or a
pricing decision
most decisions in companies are two-way
doors like if if it's really a bad idea
you can reverse course and it it doesn't
it doesn't impact too much
and if you realize that it's easier to
try something out that people suggest
the third team Ops principle is decision
velocity
I think a company
the speed of progress in a company is
very much correlated to the speed of
making decisions
um
we try to combine the best of a
hierarchical and a consensus
organization
I think typically people thought you had
to choose either you are hierarchical
top down very fast at making decisions
but not always very informed
consensus is the opposite everyone
participates in the decision making
process they're going to be very
informed decisions but it tends to slow
things down if you Institute a consensus
making out decision process you have two
things happening fewer decisions
happening and people trying to stay
under the radar so that other people can
start chiming in slowing down their work
I get live we say look the
the kind of the the part of the decision
where we get opinions and get data
everyone can participate
but the person who does the work or
maybe their manager they make the
decision
and all these people who chimed in
they shouldn't have
they shouldn't be upset if they didn't
even get acknowledged for their
contribution it is the flip side of
being able to voice your opinion
that it won't always be acknowledged
because if we require people to
acknowledge it and defend it and
everything else
we're going to see fewer decisions and
we're going to see things flying under
the radar
and I think it's
it's very much misunderstood as a
trade-off I think you can have the best
of both worlds
decisions should be taken at the lowest
possible level
no I'm involved with decisions every day
so apparently we're not always able to
do that but we try to try to do that as
much as we can
we try to reduce politics in a couple of
ways we try to see why especially in our
handbook when we encode the decision
like this is how we operate it's
important that you have the Y there
because the it might times might change
and if you don't know the Y you never
know when to change the underlying thing
we try to work asynchronous as much as
possible
we try to embrace boring Solutions
um
there's a lot of I think computer
science people here they like new
technologies and that's great and we
encourage people using them we don't
encourage people bringing their Hobbies
into our product
because our mission is everyone can
contribute and that's only possible if
everyone understands what they're
building upon so if you make a layer in
the product that is very novel and very
interesting it's going to be hard for
other people to build on top of that so
we try to avoid that whenever possible
and we try to reduce constraints the
more constraints you have the more gates
the slower things are going to go
and the last part of Team Ops is is
Clarity of of measurement and and of
execution
we don't have a matrix organization a
matrix organization is where you report
to a functional boss and kind of
a project type of manager if you have
two managers it's going to be really
really hard to make get decisions done
and have clear sense of career progress
and things tend to get political
we measure results and not hours
I think there's still a lot of
um
presenteeism I'm actually I'm
pronouncing this right but companies
focusing on people showing up like if
you are very visible if you come in
early and you leave late they assume you
do good work
if you measure those things you're
definitely going to see people doing
that except it's not the goal of the
company to do that so for example gitlab
as a manager you're not allowed to talk
with one of your reports about how many
hours they worked unless you suspect
they were too many hours
we always want to make sure the focus is
on the result
and we discourage managers for sometimes
praising an effort
um because
if if we start celebrating kind of
people
spending a ton of time on something
you're gonna you're gonna get that
and we do we want to spend a minimal
amount of time getting the maximum
result
I think transparent measurements is also
very important for everyone to know kind
of what page they're on
in engineering we for example measure
merge request rate
how many pieces of code did you
get into production considering the size
of your team
you've measure that at the team level to
encourage collaboration
and we don't really we don't just on a
kind of an engineering level we don't
just measure what our Engineering Group
shipped us all but we include outside
contributions hundreds of improvements
in gitlab every quarter are made by
users and customers
they help us improve the product and
they they work on the same level as us
so
we don't just share our roadmap publicly
even our work in progress we had an
engineer start at gitlab and say who's
who's this kind of product manager
telling me what to do and it wasn't a
product manager it was a customer who
really cared about the feature they were
writing and were following that in real
time as they were making commits
it was funny when we started measuring
Mr rate our engineer set like hey it's
going to be really simple I can just
make smaller changes and I'll get a
higher rate and we're like yes exactly
what you should do because we know the
smaller you make it the easier it is to
review the lower the odds it will blow
up production the easier it is to make
fixes and and change things every every
change should add some value for the end
user to add some functionality or
something else but please make it as
small as you can because overall we're
going to be more productive as an
organization
we prioritize due dates over scope for
example new version of self-managed
gitlab ships every month on the 22nd and
we've hit that for as long as we existed
ever since the first release that's now
130 releases in a row because that train
just goes and it really because that is
the case people know that it brings
predictability I think people know when
something ships but also helps people
reduce scope because they know that
train is going to go so they reduce
scope in order to make the train
we have a value that's disagree commit
and disagree
we love disagreements because otherwise
there's too many people in the meeting
then at some point the dri is going to
make a decision and we expect everyone
to execute on that and implement it but
that doesn't mean that from then on you
cannot disagree
further
the execution should happen but you can
keep arguing for a different decision
the best decision they made in gitlab
history was a case of disagree commit
and disagree
there was an engineer called Camille and
he said we should combine our Version
Control and our CI our verify
functionality
into a single application and uh Dimitri
my co-founder said obviously not
[Music]
um
that is technically complex
and and no other tool does it that way
and I said obviously not our customers
do not want data in a single tool they
want composability they want unit
experience suppose compose different
tools
so we disagree and Camille commit it and
he added value to the product but he
kept coming back
and at some point we relented
um and it was the best
decision in in our history we started it
set us on a path of making a devops
platform
and it was so not intuitive that our
competitors took years to
to catch up to the same thing and we are
now ahead we have the most comprehensive
devops platform all because Camille kept
disagreeing with us
last thing we do is a key review
meetings normally you have a report
communicating up to a manager about your
work and what you did
I am the only one that's working very
cross-functionally like of course people
in the company work with other functions
but my reports are have had all the
different represent all the different
functions in gitlab
and instead of presenting to me they
present to a group of people and it's
called the key review meeting they say
hey here's the three things top of mind
for me things I'd like to I think we
should discuss here's how we're doing
according to our okrs our goals for the
quarter and here's how we're doing
Accord to our kpis the metrics that are
always important
and we do that as a group and it brings
a lot of accountability but also a lot
of transparency of what is going on and
it helps the the whole kind of e-group
and other people
um
be on the same page and then we repeat
that presentation we we give those
materials and that agenda we give them
to the entire company
and we have a group conversation where
anyone in the company can join gitlab is
now 1700 ish people about 80 people join
and
their their questions are less sharp
than the ones in the key meeting and
that's not their manager their peers
but it is a lot of questions for
clarification people who want to
understand and that's it really helps to
keep the whole company kind of informed
of everything going on allowing them to
make better decisions in their
departments
if you're interested in team Ops we we
do a certification it's free it takes
about an hour
um
and I I encourage you to do so
I think
um
what's happening in our industry right
now according to Gardner
the adoption of devops platforms is now
less than 20 but they see it tripling in
the next three years so we're looking
forward to kind of the industry
switching from multiple tools to an
integrator tool
what we also see is devops model Ops and
data Ops converging
every significant application of the
future will have machine learning
it will have code that emits data you
train models on it and it informs how
the code executes right now those are
completely different Pipelines
different ways of working different
tools stack
just like devops brought development
security and operations together I think
there's a there's a role for having an
integrated platform for that significant
application where
those things work together instead of
separate and we're adding ml Ops and
data Ops functionality to get live
I read a lot of great questions so I
hope we have ample time for that thank
you
[Applause]
any questions
good question
I'm kind of curious whether you can
comment on
um and I know this isn't exactly the
same as my kid lab does but
um whether there is an intention to do
something similar uh and what I mean by
that is what's going on right now with
GitHub and their development of co-pilot
and their use of basically you know
taking all the code that's on their
platform and utilizing it for an
external service that they're selling I
wonder if you or I'm wondering if you
had like an opinion as like how you feel
about that in terms of what it spells
for industry what it spells you know for
you know software development in general
and the legality of the whole situation
as it pertains to git lab and again the
industry at home thanks uh yeah
questions of what I think of GitHub
co-pilot I get a co-pilot is a coach
suggestion tool it's trained on code
that is some of it is open source
licensed some of it might not be
licensed in a way you'd intuitively you
you can copy it
but what co-pilot does is is not
necessarily copying it it's using it to
train and then based on training it does
something and I think that's the debate
is this copying or is this like teaching
a student and then the student yes has
ideas in the future and I think over the
coming months and years where we're
going to see people
argue about that and and that's going to
bring more clarity I think it's uh
it's a it's a useful tool quote
suggestions make a ton of a ton of sense
and we're working on those
um
we think that there's lots of areas in
which
um a devops platform can benefit from Ai
and ml
and the feature we've released doesn't
help an individual coder work faster but
it helps with the overall speed the
cycle time and that's it it helps you
determine who should I assign this code
review to
because if you look at speeding up the
time between making something and
getting it out there most of the time
isn't lost because people cannot type
fast enough most of the time is lost
because you assign it to the wrong
person who doesn't have expertise on
that part of the code base and then it's
kind of stuck there for days
so
um we're focused
on making it a lot better we'll have
Coach suggestions too but um
we'll also do other things to to make
the app better apart from that we want
to make sure that gitlab got gets better
for
ml Ops and we're starting day or two
with small functionality what we just
released is the ability to use ml flow
to inform an experiment in gitlab link
to two together
so I love that you published the
handbook and you also mentioned the
public by default so I would like to
hear more about the rationale behind
making a lot of information probably
yeah we make so much public
it started because we started a
for-profit company around an open source
project
and what typically happens is the amount
of contributions goes down
and I thought
if we are very open about how what we do
as a company but also how the company
functions who are there who's
responsible for what
um we're gonna better be able to to have
the wider Community kind of join in that
journey and also call us out when
something goes goes astray
and
that worked Maybe
correlation is not causation but we have
more contributions now than we had than
when we started the company
what we discovered over time is that it
really became a way for us to attract
Talent
people
I recently had an interviewer say look I
looked at your handbook and I feel like
corporate soul mates now
might be
stating it a a bit definitive but a lot
of people say look I looked at your
handbook and this is the I I can
sympathize with that this is the way I
want to work there's also probably some
people who I never speak to or like look
at our handbook and say I'm not a fit
for this company
and I think that's fine too I think it's
always a bit curious when a company
doesn't tell you their strategy but day
one you show up they tell you the
strategy and they expect you to be
totally aligned with their strategy and
way of working well you should have told
me before I joined and I think it's it's
a way to see whether whether you're a
good fit
and I think companies used to be
constrained to a certain metro area so
you kind of had to be appealing to
everyone
it's no longer the case we can hire we
have people in 60 countries we just need
a few people to be really excited about
Gilma
and I'm recently we've seen that it also
now started to lead to customers being
more interested in us and people say
like hey yeah I compared you to what we
our DIY devops and one reason to switch
was your transparency
thanks
curious about your name about the
company is it a tip of the hat to get it
done
yeah for sure the name
um
when a git was made by a line of
strovals he also made Linux
um and uh
in English a git is an unpleasant person
so he he joked he named both his
projects after himself
um
get came with something that's called
get wet it was a way it was written in C
you could run it locally
to have
a web view of your repositories can do
anything but you could kind of browse
them
GitHub came after that and gitlab came
after that
so we all Trace back to get
I was wondering if you were talking
about like your hardest job is reducing
the size of work that gets to
um yeah like can you talk more about
like
some Frameworks that you use that uh
that have helped you with that things
that like changes in how you do that uh
over the years
yeah the questions about the iteration
value how do you do that
um
I think one thing to recognize is that
it comes from a really good place to
want to do something Broad in scope
just like most of you
um
the people at gitlab are very ambitious
like they want to achieve a lot and you
start thinking about something impactful
and meaningful to do and all the things
they could do and they come up with a
big plan to do something
and then it's really hard to kind of
Whittle this down to a thing that is so
small and sculpt that you're almost
ashamed to ship it
and it's it's not intuitive it's not
particularly Pleasant
um and it sometimes takes almost an
external view to do that
so if you Google gitlab iteration office
hours you'll you'll see a bunch of
YouTube videos of us discussing these
projects together and sometimes we're
able to reduce the miscope and sometimes
it's not possible
it's different solutions and most of the
time it's like okay can you drop that
requirement without kind of while still
having a positive impact
foreign
what's the senior Shadow food
yeah thanks for asking the CEO Shadow
program that you asked about is
um people being in about 80 percent of
my meetings it's two Shadows at a time
graduate between 30 and 40 people
and
I had at a certain time the realization
that
I see a lot of the company in my
meetings I see all the different
functions
and
we're a functionally organized company
so the hardest thing in the company if
you're there is to look outside your
function and I have this great
perspective
and we decided to open it up to people
first we did three weeks I was inspired
by medical tradition of
c121 teached one
but we
it was the shorter the better because
people are taken away from their day job
it's a full-time program
and we've made it smaller
and if you Google gitlab CEO Shadows
you'll find what people say about it but
it tends to give them a lot of insight
and how the company is operating how we
work
and they're able to bring that back to
their job in a function and kind of be
better at that
I I secretly and not so secretly also
hope that that's going to inspire some
people to uh maybe start their own
companies in the future also inspired
inspired some people to definitely not
start their own company in the future
and I think both both are good good
outcomes
so related to that there's this notion
of situation with leadership
most of the time requires
cross-functional View
um can you talk a bit about that
yeah next the question is a situational
leadership
and it's a it's a big subject that could
be a lecture all right in and of itself
um
here are the
a situation situational leadership is
much broader than just delegation
but as an example here are the 19
factors that I sometimes I don't do this
every for every decision but I sometimes
on delegating something I consider one
of these things
what is the experience level of the
report what are the skills required
what is my own school like how good am I
at this
how important is this how urgent is this
an urgency and importance are different
things
how many opportunities will I have to
provide feedback how many times can we
can we make improvements and you can you
can read the rest
I think
um
if you're a good leader sometimes you
are
you are delegating and it's almost like
you're not there and they're they're
completely on their own sometimes you're
delegate you're not delegating at all
you're micromanaging you're on top of it
and probably
both styles are called for in different
situations and everything in between it
so it's a really big decision like okay
how much follow-up do I require in what
way etc for example frequently I'll give
feedback and say hey
this is good to go you can publish it
please consider this additional thing
that way that person is unblocked and no
longer a gate and they can decide
whether to take my advice or not if it's
bad advice they can just ignore it
um but that's it if you want to have an
impact
you gotta
motivate people
to to do things you got to make sure
they deliver good work
and if you want to micromanage
everything you're not going to get
anywhere
but if you if you delegate everything to
an extent that you don't have control or
you have very little opportunity for
feedback that's also not appropriate if
it's a very important task
so you go first how did you identify the
need for be allowed to exist when you're
creating a company and then how did you
go about creating the first version
[Music]
start existing
um my co-founder Dimitri was
working and he needed a tool to
collaborate
he would like to have purchased GitHub
at the time but there was no budget
being a programmer he said okay well
there's no money but how hard can it be
I'll just build my own version of it
and in the first year 300 people
contributed to that effort
I saw it Dan that was on Hacker News
I thought this makes so much sense that
something you collaborate with is
something you can also contribute to
and I did a show Hacker News of hey I'm
gonna run this as a service you don't
have to download it anymore you can just
log in to gitlab.com
a year later I had was not making any
money with gitlab.com but I had all
these Silicon Valley companies that
reached out like we're running gitlab
like can you help us improve
functionality and fix things that are
wrong
and Dimitri tweeted to the whole world I
want to work on gitlab full time
so send them an email like hey I'm that
person a year ago who told you
hey I'm going to start gitlab.com
without you hope you don't mind to which
he replied great go for it it's open
source that's the whole idea
but I saw your Tweet maybe maybe you can
partner up maybe I can make sure you uh
you get a monthly income we agreed on a
monthly income I went to the local
Western Union money office
in the Netherlands and they said money
to the to Ukraine no
do you know this person or is this
someone you met over the Internet
because they were very afraid I was
being scammed but uh I was quite
convinced he was the real deal and he
was and a year later we incorporated a
year later we participated in y
culminated 2015 we were seven eight
people at the time
and uh
yeah that we were three months in the
home in the Mountain View
24 000 for three months I still remember
thinking that was a lot of money and
um yeah classic kind of laptops in the
living room
and uh we raised money and off to the
Off to the Races
so what was the first product that you
were selling going from the open source
yeah the first product we were selling I
don't remember
um but after a while we noticed a
pattern we were looking for a pattern in
like what functionality was open source
and what was proprietary and we first
thought maybe it's the size of the
company that cares about it nah maybe
it's the maturity of the company that
cares about it yeah
we tried a couple of things and then we
found it
it's not
any of those it's who cares about it
most is it an individual contributor is
it the developer security or operations
person or is it an executive at the
company
if it's an executive
it's going to be paid if it's an
individual or contributor it's going to
be open source and we call that
buyer-based open core
and if you Google Firebase hope and core
you'll you'll find a talk I did at a
heavy bit that explains it a bit more in
depth
about like what your what like your poor
it
um or if and since it's an open source
providing such a big company
um if it's not IP if there's not
anything like patent or anything like
what
what what is it
what is our core IP it is the
proprietary functionality of gitlab
so gitlab is open core that means some
of it has open source some of it is
proprietary you got to get a
subscription with gitlab to use it now
one thing is very unlike proprietary
software that you're used to even the
proprietary code is out there you can
download it you can legally modify it
you can send us contributions
just that in order to legally use it you
need to get a license with us
how do you get how do you get boys to
adopt and internalize
gitlabs culture
yeah how do we get new employees on
board with with all these things
many different ways I just did a call
today for new people who joined us in
the recent weeks and and we talked that
basically it's them asking me questions
it's an Ama
we also have a pretty extensive
onboarding the Google gitlab onboarding
you find a page and if you click through
you'll find a template you'll find in
that template is over 200 tasks that
have to be performed
and one thing I personally really like
it's not just the task you have to
perform but also the task your manager
has to perform Finance people out Etc so
if they're not doing their part of it
you know it it's not something that
surprises you six months down the road
when you need access that to that one
system
um and there's a lot of reading and and
taking tests in that there's also things
like coffee chats where we require you
to have coffee chats with five people
where you have a zoom meeting of 25
minutes with someone you haven't talked
to before
No Agenda can talk about work or life
outside of work but to make it normal to
have kind of that water cooler talk in
an online company
so
[Music]
um I guess you put a lot of thoughts
into building the culture of the world
and I think after coffee we saw a spike
Indianapolis
they are trying to still sell 15 points
under the future of wall so I was just
wondering what do you see as the biggest
pain point that you today would like to
see like companies try to solve
now the question is what pinpoints can
be solved there's so many companies
trying to contribute to making remote
better
first of all I'm very grateful for some
of the tools we use besides gitlab Zoom
slack that's that's really a game
changer
I think
um the hardest thing is to work handbook
first
so we
at a typical company if you look at
their handbook it doesn't contain
everything it contains lots of stuff
that's out of date and there's lots of
overlap and everything else
and the way we prevent that is in gitlab
if you want to communicate a change you
have to change the handbook and say hey
look this is how I change the handbook
that is not intuitive people much rather
send an email give a PowerPoint anything
but actually changing the handbook but
if you're able to kind of
to have that happen people can be more
assured that what's in the handbook is
actually the single source of Truth and
and consult it but that's that's been
hard
um
I think it's also really important that
when changing the handbook there's a
difference between who makes the
suggestion and who approves it if you
make that the same which is typical and
Wiki becomes really hard because the the
people who approve it maybe don't have
the time and the people who can make the
change maybe are not
are not sure it's the right change and
they want someone to review it
um
emphasized uh to understanding the why
why you have like a certain policy in
the case that you need to change it
so what's the why and also in what
circumstances do you imagine
so what's the why behind
that rule or okay
um so what's the why is it important to
give the why so
um
we try to always have it obvious why
something exists so that when something
no longer serves its purpose it can be
removed I think you'll find that
companies that existed for a longer time
have
more rules and more
things you need to comply with
that can be maybe you live you learn I
think
now that on the him I have more rules
for myself than I was 20 so kind of
makes sense but also you tend to overdo
it a bit and every time there's a
problem kind of introduce a new rule so
it's important to read those out and to
allow people to challenge that
um
and I'm thinking of making it even kind
of a job requirement and maybe kind of
something that factors into promotions
like how much
how many rules you were able to clean up
and were able to address in different
ways or able to make a case that
trying to prevent that mistake is worse
from accepting that it sometimes will
happen
I know that you know my action is
getting better in the last few years so
how does this web create new features to
compete against GitHub actions and all
the GitHub equal systems
how do we compete with GitHub so
um
what we see is the bar for us is not
GitHub but it's the best in class
competitor in every part of the space
think of planning lots of companies
still use jira for planning
we're now more and more able to replace
that
I think our Version Control our CI is
already really good
but we also want to make sure our
package management is great we're
competing with jfog artifactory there
our security we're not we're competing
with companies like sneak and check
marks varicode
Etc so making sure that in every single
part of that whole workflow that goes
all the way to releasing monitoring
governance and everything you become
Best in Class over time
because right now some of the parts of
gitlab are not as good as the Best in
Class things so you have to make a
compromise
now the compromise is probably gitlab
right now if you move to gitlab you can
consolidate spend you don't have all
these people working on Integrations
they can move on and do something useful
people become more effective and you get
to move faster on your biggest
priorities
but I love for it not to be a trade-off
and get both Best in Class and a single
application
on the question uh we talked about the
functional organization in the company
and the situational leadership but
within each function
inductive Team Dynamics do you follow uh
like this concept of
teams like Amazon started with or
where do you choose to decide that a
team is too big or too small
yeah when is the team too big we try to
make sure that no manager has more than
10 reports so every quarter we discuss
the managers that have more than 10
reports and what the plan of action is
for that because if I think if typically
10 you don't have time to be a good
Mentor to all of your reports and be be
familiar with their work and everything
else
um
I think that's that's one way to prevent
it I do think that smaller sometimes
beautiful and one thing we have is
incubation engineering where we have
what we call single engineer groups it's
a single person who is responsible for
planning something making something
promoting that to the outside world and
making that happen
and I think there's
a team of one person can sometimes do
remarkable things because your team
meetings are just in your head and we
try to stimulate that and
kind of having that Heritage of everyone
can contribute and all these outside
contributions allows that model to work
much better than I think than is
possible in other companies
talk a bit about the IPO what were the
threats at the time and looking back
what were the learning to have
yeah IPO learnings actually we published
a blog post about a week ago well it was
October 14th on the anniversary of the
IPO
and I think that contained a lot of the
the lessons we had
um I'm very grateful for kind of
how well it went it was one of the most
perfect things that we did in our our
history and uh
a big part of that is having an amazing
DNA team DNA's Finance people
and legal
and those functions have to do a lot of
the work for the IPL and having very
experienced people there who've gone
through IPOs before was it was a big
part of the reason why it went so well
and I recommend the blog post we we've
written up like more than 20 Concepts
that I didn't know about before we went
into the process
I really admire you know the move that
you make like you know your philosophy
or no offices
uh people like remote first what are the
learnings the things that you believe
became harder because of the distance or
the things that you haven't figured out
how to do it but no yeah
what became harder about being remote
first
I think it became easier over time
and I think one thing is
really interesting is that people kept
asking how does this old remote culture
or if you scale
and
my return to that is how does an
in-person culture scale I get the
benefit of being in one room totally get
it but then you're
no longer in one room you'll run floor
and you're multiple floors
first time I see you I've been here
three months work on the 31st floor oh
oh yeah cool
from buildings
different cities
different metropolian areas like I can't
drone on a wow
how do you scale that like if the
benefit is being in a room together how
does that scale I don't understand it
and I don't think it does
I can tell you how written culture
scales you'd write it down once people
read it multiple times
that's worked for civilization
now the only thing I think is really
important is that you reinforce certain
things
how we do a presentation that's much
easier to communicate than what our
values are
that in-person values
what happens to that they get diluted
you hire more people you sometimes like
hire so many people that most of the
people in the company were there for a
very short time
we got 22 ways in which we reinforce our
values I've not met a company that has
written down more than three ways in
which they reinforce it
so I think
obviously
I've written reinforced culture skills
much better than
counting on people being in the same
room because because that doesn't happen
at scale
so you have a very structured way right
including I'm I'm impressed if I have to
read that every single time
so how do you prevent this report you
know and I get like pizza join because
they love the company Etc and you get
the best from everywhere but how do you
prevent that you're not getting into
this circle type of person that you're
missing out diversity in a way of
thinking approaching things
yeah how do we make sure we're a diverse
company
um especially when things are so
structured
maybe let's start with the first thing
things are very structured
I don't I hope it doesn't come at the
expense of unstructured thinking
today
we decided with the direct group to next
meeting invite my
singing coach and we'll be doing
tongue stretches and motorboats in the
next meeting so I'm looking forward to
that
our chief legal officer is also the
chair of our practical joke Committee of
which I'm expecting bigger output but
let's say besides that point like it it
shouldn't come at the not robots the
whole reason we have people is because
all those written down rules are not
enough
and then how you create diversity well
you instituted at every part of the
company and there's a lot that goes into
it
one thing I thought was
interesting is that
if people apply to your company
obviously you cannot discriminate
but you can decide who you reach out to
like for your Outback recruiting you can
reach out to whoever
you want and I think that's a big lever
in increasing increasing the diversity
of your team and
I'm super happy where we are in where
we've the progress we've made in gender
diversity at the company and we still
have our workout out for us and for
example ethnicity diversity
thank you
thanks for the presentation and you were
talking about how implicit communication
happens when you're in a room and that
you are formalizing that and what are
can you elaborate a good morning yeah
thanks thanks for that how do you
formalize informal communication
um
let's see how look I looky I am with
Googling for that
uh yeah for sure
um
so so maybe the first question so how do
you organize informal communication
um
this on the right hand side is just the
uh
it's not the Lexicon what is it the
table of contents of this page
so I think there's more than 15 ways in
here that we sometimes practice to do
that
the second part of your question is how
do you do that across time zones time
zones are the bane of our existence like
remote there's no distance anymore but
time zones are extremely hard
being a remote company is easy being a
company across time zones is very very
hard there's no ideal Solutions
sometimes important meetings we do twice
so that uh all our team members can
attend
but still if I talk to our team members
in Asia Pacific they don't have as
as much interaction as as good of an
experience as the people in the US and
Europe
um so it's very hard to do correctly I
don't have magical solutions to that
I do think there's certain things you
can do asynchronous a big fan of
sending small gifts to people you can do
that across time zones but you're more
likely to find out what the fun gift is
if you're in a meeting together and you
spend a little time up front before the
meeting starts talking so
no big solutions for that it's hard but
I think being intentional and
allowing a gitlab there's an agenda
before and people kind of evolve that
agenda into notes and so people got the
chance to ask questions in the meeting
even if they will not be present
themselves and then they converts the
notes or the recording afterwards to see
what the answer was
the company in terms of employees time
zone in terms of
growth rate and so on yeah sorry for not
doing that earlier the scale of the
company it's about 1700 people of run
rate of 400 million dollars
uh people across 60 countries I don't
know how many time zones but basically
around the world
we're growing last quarter we were
growing 74 year over year in Revenue our
non-gaap operating margin was 89 percent
and the last time we detailed our net
retention it was uh over 152 percent and
that retention is a metric of how much
do your existing customers spent with
you the next year
in dollar terms
and it's a good indication if it's high
especially it's above 130 people really
like what the product does for them
there's a question in the back
the presentation fascinating the way
that you've approached us from the
management perspective I'm curious with
all of this material that's over there
can you give some insight on what the
sort of viewership or readership of all
of these sort of policies is
the question is how many people read our
handbook and our our materials
um I don't have that from the from the
top of my head I think there was a
little bit about
um
so the previous before team Ops many
many months ago we talked about remote
now that was extremely relevant at the
time because of the global pandemic but
at that time over 15 000 people download
downloaded our remote Playbook and I've
heard that it got distributed in many
companies
uh 40 000 people engaged with our course
on remote Team Management on Coursera
Coursera so
we've reached a lot of people then and
uh we uh we try to reach a lot of people
with team-ups today
um
although this will be 98 plus
your view uh
essentialized on
a review on what sorry uh the
decentralized autonomies oh Dallas so my
view on doubt which is a type of crypto
organization
I think
um
I think they're very impractically
organized I think even if you look at
government you'll see that there's
a voting power and there's kind of the
government trying to do as best as they
can uh
while incorporating that voting I think
that split is not always
super clear endows and they've not been
very successful so far
I do think that over time we're going to
get better at how these organizations
are organized
even how thoughtful you are about
management generally I would think you'd
have some interesting thoughts about how
you like people in your company to give
feedback I was wondering if you talk to
them yeah how do how do we give feedback
at gitlab
um there's a lot written down hopefully
you'll find some of it if you Google get
a lot of feedback
um a few things that come to mind like
give feedback
early and often when it's still
actionable one book we recommend
everyone reads is crucial conversations
and it's a way to give people feedback
in it
in a way that's easiest to
um
incorporate for them and I think that
it's a very short book so I really
recommend that very highly it's in our
top three of books we recommend our
leadership reads
any other questions
or suggestions
criticism
anybody send the merch requests yet to
get one
go ahead oh wait wait sorry I don't
think I just heard it I asked whether
someone sent a merch request but if you
have a question request
s that have
said emerge oh
yes to take on the intersection between
Dows and open source
you see any like convergence in the
future or
intersection between Dallas the the
crypto crypto organized things and open
source
um
I'll give some other thoughts to get rid
of the crypto questions but I I do
appreciate it um
I think there's almost no overlap I
don't know of an open source protects
that that's done by a Dao
um
in open source projects you've you've
been seeing two things happening
um either it's part of a foundation or
the open source project is managed by a
company
and
a very successful foundation for example
is the Linux Foundation who's also
running the cncf which is running
kubernetes
yeah Apache Foundation there's men
a lot of them and there's a couple who
are really good and big
um that's one model the other model is a
company behind an open source project I
think elastic or redis or gitlab
I think one thing that
bothered me a little bit about that
model was that we've seen a few bait and
switches happening where the project was
open source
in the beginning and when the company
gets to a certain scale and a certain
awareness they change the license
and I spend a lot of time thinking about
that and how to prevent that
also be thinking about that because I
started a venture friend called open
core Ventures and we start companies
around open source projects
but the makers of these open source
projects said look I'm okay with
starting a company I'm just not okay
with that bait and switch happening
and we looked at length at the license
of Open Source many of our projects are
like permission using permissive
licenses like MIT
um and we couldn't find a way to
incorporate it in the license
and then we realize it's not it's not
something to solve at the level of the
license it's something to solve for the
charter of the company
so uh last week we opened core Ventures
launched
opbc the open core Ventures public
benefit company charter
and it's a charter you can incorporate
and then you're beholden to kind of
acting like a good player in open source
everything from releasing the code of
your tests to allowing benchmarking and
a bunch of other things
and not doing the beta switch not
re-licensing the project
and that brings a certain amount of
accountability if you're not doing that
you can get sued by anyone and they can
sue for damages
and we hope with that too to kind of
help
to bring kind of
more trust to companies running open
source projects gitlab is not such a
company today we just introduced it we
just started the first company the
response has been very uh very promising
and I I've heard of multiple people
considering incorporating a search now
could you tell a little bit more about
our Remote Management of the employees
there is a lot of softwares such as home
staff and stuff and such so what's your
take on your this type of software in
um time development and do you have any
suggestions or recommendations
for entrepreneurs management
yeah the question is about how managing
people remotely and the software you
need
and my personal belief is that it's not
so much about the software it's much
more about how you use the software and
I think even the kind of the default
stack for a company
that includes like Zoom Google Docs
Slack
it's much more about how you use those
tools than
um then using special software for
remote
for example all the meetings at getlab
they always have a Google doc attached
in the calendar invite there's always an
agenda there and during the meeting we
start indenting that agenda and adding
notes to it people ask questions there
so that it's clear who wants to ask a
question next because that's kind of
awkward in a remote environment
sometimes
so it's about how you use it same with
like recording a meeting like
whenever possible we try to live stream
it to YouTube like there's not special
software you need but you do need a lot
of kind of
intentionality in the company so like oh
yeah of course this is yeah nothing
secret here we can just live stream this
to YouTube it takes takes effort on the
part of the organization to to do that
and get comfortable with that
thanks
[Applause]